bonjour bruno bartocetti merci d'être
avec nous ce matin en direct sur arte
france pour parler de cette grande
marche citoyenne organisée à partir de
13 heures cet après-midi alors il ya
déjà un début de polémique avec la
présence de gérald darmanin qui a
confirmé sa présence pour soutenir les
policiers
les policiers ne sont pas contre quel
est votre point de vue bonjour c'est un
thème que citoyen puisque c'est une
marche citoyenne la venue de darmanin ne
dérange pas on n'est ni contre ni pour
celle de salsa lui appartient après vous
savez de notre côté c'est toujours ainsi
plus sensibles de s'exprimer sur sa
présence ou pas la mesure où on l'a bien
vu dans votre dans votre reportage
ça prend une dimension politique alors
le fait qu'il soit le fait qu'il soit de
notre côté aujourd'hui dans la
manifestation dans le rassemblement
c'est ça me paraît quand même
intéressant mais si nous pourrons
directement l'interpeller sur nos
conditions de travail
là le sens où il fait partie le cdu du
gouvernement et aujourd'hui si nous
appelons à cette marche citoyenne
si de nombreux policiers de nouveaux
policiers à la retraite et bien sûr de
citoyens vont se retrouver devant
l'assemblée nationale c'est pour
s'adresser à l'ensemble de la classe
politique nautique et aussi au
gouvernement dont il fait partie donc en
direct il pourra il pourra atteindre nos
revendications
on m'a confirmé justement nos
revendications et aux masses adressé
justement à ce gouvernement pour que des
réponses pénales soient soient adaptés
losc hop parce qu'on agresse un policier
écoutez on espère qu'il va continuer
aussi de talent et un peu plus loin dans
ma réponse qui va continuer à s'exprimer
lors des conseils du ministre et on va
dire les taper du poing sur la table
pour pour demander le justement et pour
devenir le porte-parole de cette
profession sur les difficultés alors
c'est la réponse pénale que vous
réclamez qu'il n'est pas assez ferme
à votre avis le premier ministre a déjà
émis quelques propositions
vous semble-t-elle suffisante alors en
tout cas intéressante car je ne veux pas
rentrer dans une opposition police
justice de ce que nous réclamons c'est
que la justice ait des moyens de
travailler ce qui n'est pas le cas vous
avez des magistrats qui ont envie de
sanctionner qui sont à l'incapacité de
le faire à part faute de moyens alors
toute la sécurité en france ne doit pas
reposer sur les épaules de la police et
de la justice elle ne sommes pas
responsables
mais nous demandons des moyens nous pour
travailler nous demandons aussi que la
justice ait des moyens pour travailler
lorsqu on est sorti de notre rendez vous
avec le premier ministre
même si nous circulaire du garde des
sceaux va être adressée à l'endroit des
tribunaux et les parts paitier on
n'allait pas à ressortir avec ce qu'on
va dire avec un décret ou un bis cas où
une circulaire a fait notre première
rencontre la dernière fois chez le
premier ministre mais pour essayer
d'être clair là ma réponse on considère
que ça devienne intéressant
après vous savez vous avez déjà des
textes de lois qui existent lorsque
parce que lors de 8 à parme
les auteurs peuvent encourir une peine
de 30 ans et qu'on applique à peine
sursis ou un rappel à la loi
les textes existent déjà on demain de
schiste l'application alors on ne venons
pas là on ne peut pas ne pas d'être
surarmés on ne demande pas non plus le
rétablissement de la peine de mort ont
demandé des sanctions sévères et adaptée
et rapide à l'endroit de ceux qui s'en
prennent aux forces de nos problèmes
vous le dit c'est pas forcément qu'il
n'y a pas de lois c'est que il y à des
remises de peine et finalement les
peines ne sont pas exécutées au final
c'est exactement ça avec les remises de
peine
on se rend compte que non nous nous
voyons qu'ils gagneraient notre notre
population et notre nôtres notre travail
se sentent impunis cent des raisons de
le passer dans la mesure où avec une
remise de peine d'un sursis et reprendre
leurs activités notamment en matière de
stups de violences diverses c'est ce qui
est navrant vous savez 50 % des délits
en france ces crimes sont commis par les
récidivistes qui représente voilà voilà
les cinq pour cent des électeurs que
nous retrouvons régulièrement l'aller
les geôles de garde à vue
quand il est vrai que ça devienne cette
guerre qu'en est il de votre possibilité
de vous défendre
certains disent que vous n'êtes pas
assez formés au maniement des armes par
exemple est-ce que ça aussi c'est un
problème
oui alors pour remettre en cause de la
formation d'ailleurs nous avons bien
évidemment vous savez moi au delà de la
formation continue à on peut pas
remettre en cause le travail de nous
deux nous formateur donc de nos
moniteurs
je crois que ce qui est important de
retenir c'est qu'on était revenu à une
scolarité de six mois pour les élèves
gardiens
c'est vrai qu'une information des jeunes
paraît beaucoup plus adaptée beaucoup
plus efficace voilà ça c'est important
mais il a fallu aussi recruter
rapidement savez nous dit on pas qu'on a
perdu ce réseau me de cet impôt ce
policier j'adore main entre 2004 et 2012
on a recruté depuis 2012 à recruter
régulièrement mais il a fallu renforcer
des services comme la dgsi lrt et harpe
luth a massivement et rapidement on a
voulu réduire la scolarité à six mois et
c'était suffisant alors c'est difficile
de se remettre
on va dire du club marino quand vous
commandiez dans notre jargon sur la voie
publique rapidement et c'est pour cette
raison qu'on était redescendu à six mois
de formation revenons maintenant ce sera
déjà pas sérieux merci beaucoup une
bonne eau bartocci thing on a
malheureusement plus le temps de
poursuivre cette vaste vaste question on
vous retrouvera évidemment pour couvrir
cette manifestation
marche citoyenne en tout cas à paris cet
après midi